two weeks from now DNC deputy chairman
keith ellison may become the Attorney
General of the state of Minnesota this
despite allegations of abuse that have
been leveled at him by his ex-girlfriend
CaroMont Karen Monahan Karen Monahan is
a liberal she's a Democrat but she's
also complained about the poor treatment
she's received from fellow Democrats
since she was bold enough to go public
with her allegations has anything
changed in the weeks since she said that
with Karen Monahan and her attorney
Andrew Parker join us tonight thank you
both for coming on Thank You Tucker
thank you
so Karen you had said publicly that
since coming forward with your claims
against keith ellison that you were in
effect blacklisted by fellow democrats
can you describe what she meant when you
said that well I think if you look on
social media if you see some of the
letters that have been written that
basically say they don't believe me the
folks who have signed on you it's pretty
apparent there's been a lot of bullying
there's been a lot of harassment
isolation by many folks that I stood
side by side with I'm supporting them in
their campaigns walking with in in
various protest work together on
different issues around social justice
we're using that's not the reception
that people who say they're survivors of
abuse expect they're gonna get from the
left from Democrats were you surprised
by it no I watched the me2 movement it
was you know both but I've watched both
sides basically take women's pain and
use it as a tool for politics and once
it came to one side or the other you
would see these same people start
pushing away from it and saying stuff
like well let's talk about
real issues and this is a real issue
Andrew Parker do you think that the
Democratic organization in Minnesota
investigated this in a legitimate way
these claims
no it wasn't legitimate at all any
objective review of it would reach the
same conclusion the Democratic National
Committee kicked it to the DFL party in
the state of Minnesota who hired their
lawyer to investigate their candidate
for attorney general and not just their
candidate Tucker for attorney general
but cause celeb for the Democratic Party
a leader of the progressive movement not
just in Minnesota but nationally the
vice chair of the Democratic National
Committee is who they were investigating
and they hired their own lawyer not an
outside independent lawyer the Wrangler
and and a law firm that raised over half
a million dollars for Democratic
candidates and over $50,000 for Keith
Ellison himself
yeah that's not legitimate Karen you
have said or allegedly there is a video
that shows you being dragged off the bed
by keith ellison him swearing at you
does that video exist yes will the
public have a chance to see it well the
public will not have a chance to see it
that's my pain and for something like
that for everybody to look at in Google
over something that was very
traumatizing for me absolutely not I
would not allow the public to see it if
and when I decide to show it to somebody
it will be in my time I mean this is a
process and just to find the courage to
come out and break my silence as I said
knowing the backlash that I would get
and knowing that this is a journey that
I would walk pretty much on my own it's
a tremendous amount of courage and I had
to face the same fears that so many
others who have been victimized face
when they decide to either share their
story or not tell
shared their story it's also the same
it's also the same kind of fear that
many people who actually know about this
situation have known about it long
before I ever shared
when went public with it why they sit
silent or they're afraid to show public
support many have been bullied and
intimidated if they did come out and
show any kind of public support and I
grappled with that same fear the fear of
isolation the fear of being revitalized
that's that mirrors to feel according to
the people who are making you feel that
way thank you both for joining us then I
pre xi8 you're taking the time to talk
to us and tell us what happened Thanks
thank you so much thank you can Tucker